bonjour je m'appelle Marie Simone Dena
je cherche un poste comme femme de chamb
dans l'hôtellerie j'habite sur
Saint-Paul j'aimerais travailler dans
dans la région l'ouest et Nord j'ai fait
une formation en remise à niveau dans le
dans le centre formation la créé sur
saintol j'ai 7 ans d'expérience en
entretien des locaux et chambres en
hôtellerie j'ai travaillé comme femme de
chambre à l'hôtel swalio à Lamanda et
Beach et j'ai fait des saisons en
métropole saison d'hiver et saison d'été
au Club Med je suis autonome discrète
souriante rigoureuse euh volontaire
j'aime travailler en équipe euh je fais
le sport musculation en salle et la
marche à pied j'ai une passion pour pour
les orchidées merci de votre écoute
n'hésitez pas à m'appeler je suis
motivée pour travailler et je vous
remercie